moment that one of your parents starts
to develop these symptoms and you start
to see them go downhill it's absolutely
it's devastating
Neil Haines knew his father Walter was
dying but one of the cruelest realities
of coronavirus is families can't even
spend their final hours together I'm
like that like that died down so I
couldn't go with him I had to watch him
go off in an ambulance stand I was
standing on the pavement I had to watch
him go Walter died two hours after
arriving at the hospital in Birmingham
more people are dying from Kovan 19 in
the West Midlands than in any other
region outside London Wolverhampton has
seen a worryingly high number of deaths
here a Sports Centre is being
transformed into a food distribution hub
boxes of essentials will be delivered to
more than 30,000 people in the city
considered at risk of serious illness
obviously the further north you get
people's health isn't isn't as good in
general we know we know that
inequalities remain economic factors are
a huge issue to our own personal health
the West Midlands has reported 30 new
deaths in addition to the 40 reported on
Thursday bringing the total to 120 have
been 37 deaths at the Royal
Wolverhampton NHS Trust alone more than
at any other trust outside London the
city has a younger population than the
England average but significantly more
people with underlying health conditions
the percentage of people who are dying
after being diagnosed with kovat 19 here
in the West Midlands
is high but that doesn't necessarily
mean that people who contract the virus
in this region are more likely to die
the government's chief scientific
adviser has said for every one death we
can assume there are a thousand cases
which means the high death rate here
could indicate there are many thousands
more people in the region who have the
virus but haven't been diagnosed as
councils are told to house rough
sleepers to protect them this hotel has
become a homeless shelter but news that
a mortuary is being built at Birmingham
Airport with room for more than 1,500
bodies reinforces the grim reality this
region is facing Becky Johnson Sky News
in the West Midlands